Let me tell you my perspective. From personal experience,
data scientists today are people who have a blend
of many different skills. This Venn diagram shows a
definition of a data scientist that I like a lot.
A data scientist is someone who knows mathematics and
statistics, which allows them to identify interesting insights in
a sea of data. They also have the programming
skills to code up statistical models and get data from
a variety of different data sources. Furthermore, a data
scientist is someone who knows how to ask the right
questions and translate those questions into a sound analysis.
After doing the analysis, they have the communication skills to
report their findings in a way that people can
easily understand. In other words, data scientists have the ability
to perform complicated analysis on huge data sets. Once they've
done this, they also have the ability to write and
make informative graphs to communicate their findings to others.